for brian developing this afternoon
metro police say they have new
information on the person suspected of
murdering las vegas review journal
reporter jeff german now take a look
here police are looking for this person
dressed in an orange coat with a wide
tan sun hat and large duffel bag now
mary jane belliesa joins us in studio
with more details mary jane well
christian jeff gearman was found stabbed
to death outside his home in the
northwest valley saturday morning metro
police tell us that they believe a fight
led to his death they say it appears the
suspect seen in these photos released
this afternoon was casing the area to
commit other crimes before the stabbing
happened 8 news now's ron futrell
describes german's death as shocking
they both worked closely together
investigating the removal of jerry
tarkanian as unlv's basketball coach
yeah there are so many questions right
now we don't know answers to stuff but
i'll tell you jeff was fearless that's
one thing he was you can't do some of
the stories he did without being
fearless
in that sense
the stabbing happened near vegas drive
and rock springs metro police are asking
the community in that area to review
their video cameras at home or
businesses to see if they captured the
suspect now we did speak to some of
german's neighbors who didn't want to be
on camera they said they didn't know
gearman but didn't see anything
suspicious and offered their condolences
live in the studio mayor gene belliesa 8
news now